did he slamming claims that young Miami
is his side chick I want to get it right
this comes after Diddy's surprise
announcement that he welcomed a child
with another woman quote I'm so blessed
to welcome my baby girl love Sean Combs
to the world
et's learned the mother is Dana Tran and
she's reportedly a cyber security
specialist when the news dropped Miami
seemingly responded after fans
questioned the timeline of Diddy's
relationships
in one Swede Miami writes quote I'm
nobody side blank let's just make this
clear on this good Monday in another
quote I'm not mad I'm trending now you
want to say you want to talk and now
Diddy's taking a moment to address the
claims he writes quote young Miami is
not my side chick never has been never
will be she's very important and special
to me and I don't play about my shoddy
WAP I don't discuss things on the
internet and I will not start today
shout out to Diddy it's about him night
that he also seems to get protective
over the city girl rapper he says he
promises to show up at the house of
anyone who quote hurts someone he loves
Diddy and young Miami sparked romance
rumors over the summer and in June
during a visit on her podcast she cut
straight to the chase I wish our
relationship status
you missed the at-bag
I'm single you know
I'm single but I'm dating I'm just
taking my time with life so what we use
we date
we dating
we go have dates and we friends
okay you go to Exotic locations we have
great times we go to strip clubs
Church
I'm gonna take you to church
I love it he started things off saying
he was single but later on did he dove
into their deep connection I mean
because you authentic
you know you're like one of the realest
people I ever met you know what I'm
saying and you know authentically
yourself
and your great mother and you know
a great friend you just have a good time
while things may look good for these two
the Stars got his hands full now that
he's welcomed his seventh child he has
four kids with the late comporter Quincy
who he adopted King and twins Jesse and
Delilah Diddy's also fathered to Justin
with Misa Hilton and chance with Sarah
Chapman
[Applause]
first of all the biggest thing that's
going on tonight is me bringing my
daughter to this because she's an
aspiring actress and we get to have a
date and I'm just so excited and I'm
just so stunned I'm at a loss of words
when she walked out right what what did
you say what did you do right
[Music]
what's up
[Music]